[Música]
en directo América llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ellos saludo en
el estudio de mi compañera Daniela
Blandón Daniela hace rato no nos
acompañaba en directo América edición
nocturna estar aquí de nuevo Y empezamos
hablando de Argentina porque hay nuevos
tipos de dólar Andrés todos sabemos que
en este país hay más de una docena de
tipos de dólar diferentes que van desde
el llamado Blue en el mercado informal
hasta el Netflix o el soya el gobierno
creó algunas más como una manera de
frenar la pérdida de reservas haciendo
más costoso su uso el primero se está
conociendo como dólar Coldplay en
alusión a la banda británica que estará
Próximamente en este país y que tendrá
un recargo del 30% en bancos y en casas
de cambio será aplicado para la
contratación de artistas extranjeros que
den conciertos en la nación y para
actividades deportivas que impliquen
algún giro por pago en el exterior el
segundo es el llamado denominado dólar
Qatar con una tasa del 25% y llamado así
por los mayores gastos que esperan por
el mundial de fútbol por qué Porque va a
aplicar por ejemplo para pasajes y
tiquetes turísticos o tiquetes y pasajes
turísticos al exterior superiores a 300
dólares también se dispuso un tipo de
cambio diferencial para la compra en el
exterior de bienes santuarios o de lujo
y cuyo valor es idéntico al Dólar Qatar
se usará para compras de bienes que van
desde automóviles y motos de alta gama
hasta jets privados también bebidas
alcohólicas Premium relojes y piedras
preciosas Daniela cambiamos de tema la
huelga en la refinerías de Francia
tienen origen en las grandes ganancias
de las petroleras hagamos un repaso a
estas cifras pues Andrés los operadores
de las refinerías En paro que tienen al
menos a una de cada tres gasolineras en
el país sin combustible son la francesa
total energys y la estadounidense con
Móvil navegamos por los más recientes
resultados financieros disponibles que
corresponden al primer semestre de este
año frente al mismo periodo de 2021 toda
la energys sus ventas mundiales en 67% a
más de 130 mil millones de dólares
mientras que sus utilidades casi se
duplicaron a 10.000 millones de dólares
Si nos vamos por Epson móvil superó los
200 mil millones de dólares en ingresos
en los primeros seis meses de este año
60% más y sus ganancias más que se
triplicaron los trabajadores exigen que
basadas en estos mejores resultados Pues
que se han dado en parte también debido
a los altos precios del petróleo que ha
dejado la guerra en Ucrania estas
compañías le suban sus salarios para
hacer frente a la enorme inflación bien
vamos ahora a Reino Unido porque la
primera ministra compareció ante el
parlamento para defender su plan
económico Así es Andrés Pues el
principal temor de sus detractores es
que reduzca el gasto público para poder
pagar la enorme deuda que le va a
generar este controvertido plan de
crecimiento que se basa principalmente
en recortes de impuestos la primera
ministra listos en su primera
comparecencia ante el parlamento desde
que prese este plan dijo seguir
absolutamente comprometida con este plan
de no recordar la inversión Estatal sin
embargo Esos planes sembraron el caos en
los mercados financieros tienen la libra
esterlina en niveles bajos no vistos
hace años y a la bolsa de Londres
perdiendo por sexto día consecutivo
momento de conocer los indicadores
en rojo después de la publicación de las
actas de la reunión de septiembre de la
reserva Federal que mostraron a algunos
funcionarios preocupados por la
persistencia de la alta inflación a
pesar de que se vienen subiendo las
tasas de interés si nos vamos para
América Latina las bolsas también
tuvieron pérdidas con un mercado muy
ansioso por conocer el dato de inflación
en Estados Unidos correspondiente a
septiembre que dará luces sobre si las
tasas de interés va a seguir subiendo y
que se conocerá este jueves y nuestra
cifra del día Daniela un millón de
dólares Andrés lo invito a que tenga esa
esa cifra por allá anotada y le digo Por
qué el multimillonario y los musk apostó
a capitalizar otra de sus extravagancias
esta vez a cualquier al mercado un
perfume llamadoir o cabello quemado que
se suma a otros como su propia marca de
tequila o hasta la 50.000 gorras que
lanzó en su momento con el logo de
Warren Company que es su empresa de
ventas El Magnate dijo en Twitter que ya
había vendido 10.000 perfumes a 100
dólares cada uno o sea ese millón de
dólares que le acabo de decir e invitó a
sus usuarios a que sigan comprando para
que él pueda adquirir Twitter no le
faltan sino 44,999 millones un poquito
No mucho y nos preguntamos a qué hora
era un perfume llamado cabello quemado
Daniela Muchas gracias por la
información económica seguimos con más
aquí en directo América